welcome back where we left the last
problem we essentially found ourselves
having to solve this equation right over
here and where we left off we said well
maybe just maybe we might be able to
simplify this a little bit if we can
find some common factors between the
numerator and the denominator and I want
to do it here because if I multiply this
out and multiply it times the square
root of 3 and then subtract it or add it
to that so that I actually so I got just
a straight-up polynomial that
polynomials gonna have the square root
of 3 and it's gonna be really really
messy thing it's still going to be
fourth to degree and at least this way I
have some chance of being able to solve
it at least I just have integer
coefficients over here and the only way
that this is going to simplify is if it
has any common factors with the stuff
down here and when you look over here
this actually this right here is
actually going to have complex roots if
you did the negative B plus or minus B
the square root of b squared minus 4ac
over 2a the b squared minus 4ac over
here is actually going to be negative so
it's not going to have any real roots so
that does not is not going to have any
easy real roots but this is the x
squared plus one that has X plus 1 and X
minus 1 or another way to think about it
is roots to this are negative 1 and
positive 1 so if either of those are
roots to this then we're in business and
actually there's a just looking at this
there's a decent chance because in
general if you want to think about the
roots of a of 8 well really any nth
degree polynomial the roots if you think
about let me just draw it over here if I
have a bunch of roots X minus r1 X minus
r2 x minus r3 and then let's say we have
a fourth degree X minus r4 so let's say
we have four roots when you multiply
this whole thing you're gonna have X to
the fourth plus buh-buh-buh-buh-buh all
the way and then the last term over here
the last term over here is going to be
r1 r2 r3 r4 it's going to be the product
of all of these and so if you want to
put this equation right or this
expression in this form you divide both
sides by or divide the whole expression
by two or you can kind of say well let's
just look at this thing and divide it by
two and then you would have
to the fourth plus 2x with all of that
plus 1/2 and so this thing would have to
in this context be equal to 1 over 2 and
away this is kind of a it's not a fail
proof technique but it is one way to
kind of discover roots and you say ok
the roots could be the factors of this
divided by the factors of that and 1 is
definitely a factor of both of those and
actually if you think about it negative
1 can be as well so we feel good but
let's actually try it out instead of
going through all of this argument let's
actually see if either one or negative 1
are factors of this thing up here if
they're not then we just have to move
ahead and if you multiply multiply this
thing out multiply it by square root of
3 and then just solve but we can we can
hope usually usually the test writers
aren't that big status otherwise it
wouldn't be that it would be impossible
to solve so I'm feeling good about this
so let's just try it with one so if we
try one here so let's put one here and
see if we get 0 over here so if we get 2
times 1 to the fourth plus so let me
just write that so 2 times 1 to the
fourth is just 2 plus 2 times 1 to the
third is just 2 minus 3 times 1 squared
is just 3 minus 2 plus 1 so this is 4
minus 5 plus 1 that indeed equals 0 and
let's try negative 1 let's try negative
1 so this is 2 times negative 1 to the
fourth so that's still 2 plus 2 times
negative 1 to the 3rd so that's negative
2 minus 3 times negative 1 squared
that's negative 3 and then minus 2 times
negative 1 so it's plus 2 plus 1 so this
is 0 minus 3 plus 2 plus 1 this also
cancels out this also gets us 0 so we
now know that both X plus 1 and X minus
1 are factors of this thing up here or
another way to think about it is their
product is a factor of this thing up
here x squared minus 1 is a factor of
this so if we were to divide x squared
minus 1 into this we should get a
reasonable answer we shouldn't get a
remainder I guess I should say so let's
do that
so we read a little practice doing
polynomial long division so if we divide
x squared minus 1 into into this thing
up here
two x to the fourth plus two x to the
third minus three x squared minus 2x
plus one so this is good practice on
polynomial long division highest degree
term going into highest degree term x
squared goes into 2x to the fourth 2x
squared times so let's put that in the 2
X Squared's bott 2x squared 2x squared
times x squared is 2x to the fourth 2x
squared times negative 1 is negative 2x
squared and now let's subtract this from
up there so let's we're multiply it by
negative one and then add it and so this
gives us this gives us 2x to the third
negative 3 plus 2 so it's minus x
squared minus 2x plus 1 and then x
squared goes into 2x to the third 2x 2x
times so this is plus 2x 2x times x
squared is 2x to the third 2x times
negative 1 is minus is negative 2x and
then we can subtract this from there or
you could say add the negative so let's
just add the negative it's easier to
keep track of things so those cancel out
you get negative x squared these cancel
out plus 1x squared goes into negative x
squared minus or negative 1 times
negative 1 times x squared is negative x
squared negative 1 times negative 1 is
positive 1 and indeed we get no
remainder so we can write this thing up
here
we can write it as the product of this
so it is equal to so this thing we can
rewrite as 2x squared plus 2x minus 1
times x squared minus 1 so this times
this is equal to this so times x squared
minus 1 so we just factored it and so
that simplifies things a good bit it
doesn't make it trivial but it
simplifies things a good bit so now we
can cancel that with that and now at
least we have things in second degree we
got rid of these third and fourth degree
terms so let's now rewrite things
so now let's multiply both sides of this
equation by x squared plus X plus 1 so
we're going to get the square root of 3
so let me just write it out so I'm going
to get the square root of 3 times x
squared plus the square root of 3 times
X plus the square root of 3 times 1 so I
just multiplied the left-hand side by
this what's we have left in the
denominator is equal to is equal to what
we have left in the numerator because if
we multiply the right side by this it
obviously cancels out so this is going
to be equal to 2x squared plus 2x minus
1 minus 1 and now if we want to
so let's now put this now let's see what
we can do here well we can subtract we
can subtract these from we could
subtract the stuff on the right side
from the left hand side and so we would
get the square root of 3 minus 2 times x
squared times x squared plus the square
root of 3 square root of 3 minus 2 minus
2 times X just subtracting this stuff
from that side plus the square root of 3
plus 1 right did I do that right
square root of 3 I subtracted the x
squared from that so square root of 3
minus 2 square root of 3 minus 2 and
they have the square root of 3
subtracting a negative 1 I get a plus 1
over here and since I subtracted all of
this stuff from both sides of the
equation this is just the left-hand side
the right-hand side is now 0 I
subtracted this from the right-hand side
to get 0 so now we have this almost
looks ridiculously simple Divac no have
these ridiculous radicals and all of
that I have a straight-up quadratic a
straight-up quadratic equation right
here so I can use the quadratic formula
so the roots here so X is going to be
equal to negative B this is B right here
so negative B you can swap those so it's
2 minus the square root of 3 plus or
minus plus or minus B squared so let's
let me so let me just write it here so
square root of 3 minus
two squared minus four times a so that's
the square root of three minus two times
C well C is the entire constant term
right over there so it's times square
root of three plus 1 all of that over 2a
all of that over 2a so all of that over
this business over here so that's 2 root
3 minus 4 so we thought we're in the
homestretch but now we have to do some
major radical simplification so once
again these test writers are not
Pleasant people so let's let's try our
best to tackle this so let's go into
let's go inside of the radical right
over here let's go inside of the radical
right over here and you have the square
root of 3 minus 2 actually you know what
I'm gonna leave you there I'm poaching
10 minutes and frankly I need a drink of
water this problem is maybe the most
tiring problem I've ever done I'll leave
you there we just have to simplify this
in the next video